welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Avengers deleted
scenes video you probably saw recently
there were a bunch of Marvel rewatch is
happening for Infinity Saga movies
the writers and the directors of
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame recently re-watched those movies
with the comic-book people they live
tweeted all kinds of deleted scenes
extra moments in more context for what
was going on so we'll break it all down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from infinity war
or endgame on the video there were a lot
of deleted scenes and things that they
talked about but I tried to pick the top
ten biggest ones so I'll start with
number 10 the writers explained what was
going on with all the different gauntlet
scenes there were a bunch of different
versions of the Infinity Gauntlet so
they tried to clarify when Thanos
actually got the real Infinity Gauntlet
and what the other ones were created for
there was the one in Odin's vault which
was a right-handed gauntlet all the gems
were in the wrong place it's on the
wrong hand the Infinity Gauntlet from
The Avengers age of Ultron post-credit
scene is also implied to be way earlier
in the timeline than when he actually
got the Infinity Gauntlet there was the
Infinity Gauntlet from The Avengers
infinity war teaser trailer at Comic Con
2014 it's correctly the left handed
gauntlet but all the gems were in the
wrong places in the gems themselves
aren't quite the right colors there's
the actual gauntlet that he runs around
wearing during infinity wars the one
that he snaps at the end and then
there's the extra Infinity Gauntlet
sitting at eateries forge the writers
clarified that the Infinity Gauntlet
from The Avengers age of Ultron
post-credit scene was also meant to be a
fake one like the one in Odin's vault
and when Thanos first got the idea to
use all six Infinity stones to snap half
of all life he also learned about the
myth of a gauntlet that could control
the power of all six stones at the same
time so behind the scenes they refer to
this gauntlet as the quote-unquote
practice gauntlet in the one from Odin's
vault is also based on the myth of the
Infinity Gauntlet so even though
everything that Odin stores inside his
vault is implied to be real very
powerful and very dangerous
he also stores collectors items
quote-unquote which is what this fake
gauntlet is as hella says later then
right before the events
Avengers infinity war pickup he goes to
III has him construct the real gauntlet
with a special enchantments that will
allow it to control the power of all six
stones simultaneously so nine the next
big thing they revealed was the
alternate opening scene from Avengers
infinity war so thinness was going to
attack Xander to take the power stone it
was gonna be a much bigger much bloodier
version of the guardians of the galaxy
battle they were gonna destroy the
entire Nova Corps lay waste to Xander
once he acquired the power stone then
this is when we get into the origin
story of the Nova that they originally
had in the movie that was going to be
one Soul Survivor it was going to be a
Richard Ryder Nova and that was going to
be his tragic backstory everyone he knew
destroyed by Thanos so number eight
there was a really big Nova scene that
they originally wrote into the movie he
was originally going to get that Silver
Surfer scene from the comics that they
gave to the Hulk being the harbinger of
doom crashing through the sanctum and
letting Doctor Strange know that Thanos
was coming so you have to picture Nova
showing up in the sanctum and he was
gonna be a much bigger part of the movie
the reason why they got rid of this
scene of him warning Doctor Strange was
because they had gotten rid of the
alternate opening scene with them
destroying Xander and without that the
Nova origin story just didn't make quite
as much sense so I know everybody's
wondering when are they gonna bring Nova
back if they had such big plans for him
during infinity war in Avengers end game
originally they also talked about
bringing him back during Avengers
endgame but when they got rid of his
origin story scene in infinity war it
didn't make as much sense to bring him
back during Avengers end game macho man
Russo brothers how do you guys not have
any Nova Corp member in a fight against
Thanos
love the movie but just boggles my mind
didn't even have to be Richard Ryder I
look closely at that scene again there
and you will see there are thousands of
people yeah you will see Richard Ryder
in the background of a shot Easter Egg
there are a couple big space-based
movies that are happening during Marvel
phase four Kevin Feige implied that they
had talked about doing an OVA project
but there's no actual date on that so it
sounds like he'll show up in another
space-based movie then they'll do an OVA
movie at some point seven the reason why
Thanos takes his armor off after getting
the space stone at the beginning of the
movie is because once he has wielded the
power of two stones simultaneously he
stirred
to evolve from a mere warlord into a
cosmic being no one in the universe as
ebony ma says has ever wielded the power
of two stones at the same time I know a
lot of you asked for Power Rankings in
the MCU who are the most powerful cosmic
beings what I'll probably do after the
Eternals movie comes out and we get way
more of a celestial characters is I'll
do a new MCU power tier ranking for the
most powerful beings in the MCU because
once you're talking about characters
like Thor he is a genuine deity in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
even without the Infinity stones Thanos
descends from the Eternals on Titan they
were created by the Celestials to have
crazy level powers then you have the
actual Celestials then you have cosmic
entities and then you have situations
where you have the Celestials using
Infinity stones themselves so when
you're asking who is top tier powerful
in the MCU that actually changes a lot
just depending on what kind of gear
people are using so don't worry we'll do
all kinds of Power Rankings through
Marvel phase 4 as they introduce new
characters I'm what's called a celestial
sweetheart celestial like a god
small geez 6 this is actually a funny
one the writer said that they based the
Iron Man Doctor Strange relationship
dynamic on Frasier and Niles crane from
the TV show Frasier you can argue about
who's Frasier and who's Niles in that
scenario now some of the comedic beats
in the iron mage twist later in the
movie make a little more sense I've
already done a whole separate video for
the iron mage deleted scene with iron
man becoming Doctor Strange in Doctor
Strange becoming iron man so I'll post a
link to that at the end of this 5
originally Captain America wasn't
supposed to appear so early in the movie
he was supposed to get the Thor Wakanda
scene it would have been a big hero
reveal as Stannis is running the
Avengers gauntlet on his way to take the
mine stone from vision they were gonna
dogpile him in a much bigger way it was
gonna be a much bigger scene but with
Captain America they just felt like it
was cheating the audience to make them
wait almost two and a half hours to see
Captain America after not having seen
him since the spider-man homecoming
post-credits scene yelling about
patience
speaking of spider-man far from home and
all the jokes they make about him being
a war criminal pretty sure cap is a war
criminal now they actually said the
sokovia cords are still in effect
after Avengers endgame so they'll cover
that stuff during the Falcon and Winter
Soldier TV show number 4 during Thanos
and dr. Strange's fight they had the
Living Tribunal deleted scene I've
already done a couple videos about this
but is basically Doctor Strange taking
him on the cosmic tour of the multiverse
that the ancient ones sent Doctor
Strange on during the first Doctor
Strange movie at the end of that he
takes him to be judged by the Living
Tribunal but because he always snapped
the gauntlet at the end of the movie
it's implied that the Living Tribunal
either didn't try to stop him or Thanos
somehow use the power of the stones that
he did have to overpower the Living
Tribunal 3 they clear by how famous new
Iron Man and what he meant when he said
they're both cursed with knowledge so he
said that he was watching Ironman blow
up two shatori fleet during the first
Avengers movie with that nuke that's how
he knew who Iron Man was then when he
says they're both cursed with knowledge
what he's referring to is they both
witnessed the destruction of their
planets now Ironman only saw it in a
vision that was given to him by Scarlet
Witch in Avengers age of Ultron but
Thanos actually witnessed Titan be
destroyed too they clarified why they
got rid of the Smart Hulk transformation
scene with him busting out of the
Hulkbuster at the end of Avengers
infinity war the hook was meant to come
back during this big wakandan battle
I've already done a full video about
that I posted the scene on my channel a
little while ago so I'll link that in
the description too they said that they
got rid of it because they felt like it
just didn't work and it was too much too
soon and they were already trying to get
across so many ideas in these final
moments of the movie so they just
decided to push that to Avengers endgame
then number one this is actually pretty
big reveal
they said that originally Captain
America was supposed to be the soulstone
Captain America himself literally the
soulstone it wasn't gonna be on for Mir
it was gonna be a separate stone part of
the reason for that idea is that Iron
Man is meant to be the heart of the
Avengers like he literally has a heart
they used that in Avengers end games
sort of call back to the first Iron Man
film Kevin Feige he's always referred to
him as the heart of the MCU and on the
other side of that because the Captain
America Iron Man dynamic is so important
to the Avengers team Captain America has
been the soul of the MCU the soul of the
Avengers this whole time the reason they
said they got rid of that is because it
just felt like it was too complex of an
idea and too confusing for audio
members like how can a person be the
stone it was just simpler to make the
soul stone an actual stone that you
could hold in your hand that was just a
fraction of the things that they
revealed I tried to include all the big
stuff but they did the same thing with a
bunch of separate scenes for Avengers
and games so I'll do a separate video
for all that extra stuff later this week
too as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see that video
when I post it but let me know in the
comments what do you think about some of
these deleted scenes and alternate
moments I know a lot of you really want
to see Nova show up in the MCU which it
sounds like he will eventually I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post my next
Marvel video you can click here for some
of those other Infinity Saga deleted
scenes that I mentioned and click here
for my venom 2 trailer video thank you
so much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]